These people are actually demonic.
They're actually satanic. They actually
genuinely are evil. They want pain and
violence and destruction for this is
putrid, wretched, repulsive. Whenever
you support literal terrorists, then
it's going to be different. These people
are demons. They're evil. They they
covet death. I think this is a great bit
of evidence that you need to completely
crush these people.
This is going to be about should
liberals defend Hassan [__] Should
liberals defend Hassan [__] What
should they say about Hassan [__] And
to start this off, we're going to watch
a Kyle Klinsky video from two days ago.
All right, this is about should Hassan
[__] be in jail? So, the fascist
terrorist imperialist bloodthirsty death
cult uh of MAGA and the Trump regime uh
they are now openly targeting political
opponents in the most disgusting way
imaginable. So, look at this. Federal
officials have allegedly subpoenaed
Hassan [__] and COP's media Benjamin
over aid mission to Cuba. The Treasury
Department has targeted the pair as part
of an investigation into whether
activists violated US sanctions in
delivering medicine and medical
equipment to Cuba. So, here's one of the
problems with this. They didn't actually
violate sanctions. In fact, they go out
of their way and they bend over
backwards to make sure they're abiding
uh by all of the rules, all the laws,
all the regulations. Um, in fact, as
Hassan himself pointed out, um, this
appears to be the case that Fox News or
the Trump regime or both fell for a
viral post that claimed that Hassan was
staying at a hotel, which is not on the
US government approved list, which means
he's, you know, economically benefiting
uh, the regime in Cuba and therefore
it's a crime. And we covered that on
stream. You guys remember that when
people were like looking up his blinds
and stuff to figure out when all of
Twitter for a a quick millisecond
decided to do the Kiwi Farms thing and
start looking up the style of blinds at
all of the hotels in Cuba? You guys
remember that? I remember that. That was
a good time. And therefore, he can be
charged. There was some viral right-wing
slop post that claimed that. Uh
meanwhile, totally untrue, completely
and utterly made up. Um they followed
the rules, followed the regulations,
went to the approved list of hotels,
went I like the energy, but Kyle is no
way to truly know that. Um, I agree with
you. I agree nobody knows for sure like
what hotel he was staying at. Like
realistically, there could just be
people lying.
But
it's whatever. As far as I know, Code
Pink is pretty dubious. And And
wait, if the Taliban wanted to donate
aid to people who were like starving,
would you go, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
The Taliban's up." Or would you go,
"Well, I guess sometimes bad groups do
good things for maybe possibly nefarious
reasons.
But like it's going to help people so
it's okay.
That's how I look at it. It's like you
could tell me Code Pink is directly
funded by China and I still wouldn't
care, you know, down the path that
they're supposed to go down. Meanwhile,
there is somebody who actually did uh
violate US law in going to Cuba and
staying at one of the incorrect hotels.
The kid's name is Nick Shirley. Yes,
Nick Shirley was just in Cuba making
some propaganda documentary and that and
he violated the rules and the
regulations and the laws. But of course,
the chances of the Trump regime going
after Nick Shirley are roughly 0%. And
the chance of them going after Hassan is
of course very very high. Now by the way
I said allegedly subpoenaed because
Hassan has actually not been served a
subpoena yet. Neither has codepinker or
media Benjamin. None of them have
actually been served subpoenas. So
there's some speculation that maybe this
is Fox News taking a viral post and
running with it uh without actually
having sources within the Trump regime
within the government. However, I do
fear even if that is the case I do fear
you will immediately see the Trump
regime sort of jump on this and try to
bring it to fruition because here's the
thing guys they don't get. They might
even know, oh, this is going to go
absolutely nowhere.
>> I did see that as well that basically
Hassan went on stream and said, I
haven't been subpoenaed, but like I do
think I'm being targeted, right? He went
out and said like, no, I've not been
served a subpoena yet. And um, you know,
it's going to ultimately end in our
humiliation. But that's not the point.
It doesn't matter. Uh, as long as they
they it's not really about Hassan. It's
not really about copinky Benjamin. It's
about everybody else who's thinking of
bucking the regime. everybody else who's
thinking about helping one of these
countries which we are terrorizing and
destroying and starving to death. That's
the point is to strike fear into people
in the same way they went after James
Comey multiple different ways. Every
single way failed instantly fell apart.
But the point is the headlines. The
point is um you know the the fear that
you put in MAGA critics, MAGA dissident
like hey shut the up. Hey don't
criticize us too much. Hey maybe we'll
muck up some charges against you. And of
course, the irony of all of this is
Trump never shut the [__] up about the
political persecution of Biden and the
Democrats going after me and all the
January sexual and it's like no you
idiot. They went after you because
you're actually a criminal. You're
charged with 91 crimes. You're 34 time
convicted felon. You actually committed
multiple crimes. You found liable in a
civil court for tax fraud and insurance
fraud. Code pink got an email from the
office of what is this off in a office
of foreign something. They have not been
served a subpoena. Media Benjamin tells
me Code Pink now has gotten an email
from the office of foreign assets
control. That's what it is. Office of
Foreign Assets Control requesting
information about the trip. Not a
subpoena, but does confirm some sort of
probe. Okay.
Honestly, I don't necessarily hate the
idea of there being a probe so long as
it's not being taken to like a legal
like a legal extent immediately. Like
people did go on a trip to Cuba. There
were a lot of there was a lot of chatter
about them staying at unsanctioned
hotels. Like if they just say, "Hey,
could you just show us your like
receipts so we could put this to rest?"
That's probably not actually government
corruption, right?
Now, if you're a total psycho and
cheering on the idea that Hassan might
be subpoenaed and might go to prison,
then that's a problem. But like, it is
if they're literally just reaching out
and going like, "Hey, just let us put
this to bed. Like, just send us your
your receipts or whatever, we'll be
fine." It's actually upholding the law
to go after you idiots. And if Biden's
justice department, if it was so biased
and they were politically persecuting
everybody, why is they went after Bob
Mendez? Why is they let charges go
against Hunter Biden? Why is it they
went after multiple Democrats? It turns
out there was no political persecution
except you guys. You're the ones doing
the political persecution. I wouldn't
want to be
>> This is all true, by the way. The Trump
administration is doing political
persecution. Even if they're not doing
it against Assan in this case, they
absolutely are. Tisha James, I wouldn't
want to be James Comey. I wouldn't want
to be Fonnie Willis. I wouldn't want to
be any of these people who actually did
their job. Jack Smith and like we're
trying to hold Trump accountable. And
now he's like, "Well, I'm going to make
your life a living hell in a mafia boss
kind of way just cuz you inconvenience
me." Like, get the out of here. So,
understand something. Why would they
target Hassan [__] Because Hassan
[__] is everything they hate and
everything they can't control and
everything they're scared of. Hassan
[__] he's out there fighting for
Medicare for all. He's out there
fighting for free college. He's out
there fighting for a living wage. He's
out there fighting against Israel, okay?
He's out there fighting against the
Epstein class who controls the Trump
regime. And they can't have that. And
why would they target Hassan [__]
Because Hassan [__] is everything they
hate and everything they can't control
and everything they're scared of. Hassan
[__] he's out there fighting for
Medicare for all. He's out there
fighting for free college. He's out
there fighting for a living wage. He's
out there fighting against Israel. Okay?
He's out there fighting against the
Epstein class who controls the Trump
regime. And they can't have that.
Especially since now he's gaining
national prominence. Especially since
now he's endorsing Democratic
candidates. And when he does that, those
Democratic candidates are going up 10
points like Abdul Elsed. Right? So, if
anything, this is going to backfire.
This is going to make Hassan a bigger
figure. He becomes a national figure. He
becomes more known. He becomes more
loved by democratic voting base cuz the
Democratic voters already love Hassan
for what he stands for if they know him,
right? They know him as the tax the rich
guy. They know him as the universal
healthcare guy. They know him as the
anti-genocide guy. Now, he's also being
persecuted by the fat imperialist
con man president, war criminal. Like
now all of them are going to go, "Oh,
well, I'm definitely on this guy's
side." Again, media Benjamin, same
thing. We love Medadia Benjamin. We love
Coping. Exact same thing. This just
makes them more prominent, more
well-known. If you wanted to find a way
to get normie Democrats to support
Hassan, you couldn't have come up with a
better plan. Normie Democratic voters
now will love this man. Now, this man
could run for a high office and win.
That's what you need to understand. So,
massive, massive miscalculation. Like I
said, uh it is possible that Fox News uh
fell into a, you know, fell for a viral
tweet that's a lie and ran with this and
there wasn't plans to go after Assad.
But my guess is that now now the fact
that they actually did that uh you will
see the Trump regime scramble to catch
up to do something like this. But of
course there's there's zero case.
There's zero case. By the way, stop and
think about this. They've not arrested
any Epstein class,
but they're arresting Hassan or
theoretically going to investigate
Hassan and subpoena Hassan and and
Medadia Benjamin for the crime of
serving ramen noodles to hungry people
for the crime of delivering diapers and
medical supplies and food to people who
need the help because our country is
illegally embargoing them and starving
them and trying to collapse the country.
I mean, what a sick joke. So
humanitarianism is a crime, but raping
children is not. According to these
demons, according to these disgusting,
I'm so sick of them, bro. I am so sick
of these criminals and these terrorists.
We're being run by like, not only do we
not live in a meritocracy, we live in an
anti-meritocracy. We're being run by the
worst people on Earth. These people are
actually demonic. They're actually
satanic. They actually genuinely are
evil. And they want they want pain and
violence and destruction for
Dude, I'm hearing it. I'm hearing I'm
hearing Vosch breaking through right now
with the Kyle rhetoric.
>> These people are demons. They're evil.
They They covet death, dude. It's
awesome. I love I love the Vosch
rhetoric breaking through. Okay,
>> for those who even 1% disagree with
them,
>> there's not a there's not a a a decent
bone in any of these people's bodies.
Okay, but I'm not done because we also
have this. Look at this. Nick Fuentes
says, "If Trump wants to win us back,
putting Hassan [__] in prison forever
would be a good start. 14,000 groper
likes. Ladies and gentlemen, Laura
Loomer, uh, the woman who allegedly
sucks off the president and controls her
like modern-day Rasputin. President
Trump can unite the entire country by
having Hassan [__] arrested. It's his
destiny." Wow. Also, is that a little
play on words I see there? Because a
little guy by the name of Destiny, and I
do mean little, a little guy by the name
of Destiny also.
>> What
a what is excited about this and thinks
it's awesome. This is putrid, wretched,
repulsive.
Just a little Just a little guy. Just a
little guy. He's just a little guy. He's
just a little tiny guy. Disgusting.
None of these people believe in
anything. None of them believe in
anything. Like I said, at the core,
they're they're an empty black void of
morality and intelligence, and it's just
I don't like this person cuz they have
more clout than me. So, I hope their
life is ruined, and I hope the
government, you know, destroys them.
>> Like, what a sick joke, man.
>> What about that other guy? What's his
name? Uh, too raw, too real or he's a
was a big comma stand and he's out there
basically cheering on Trump.
>> Yes, you heard me correctly. Cheering on
Trump. uh and saying like, "Dude, the
best part of this is okay, I'll open
that tweet Osel just sent. It's like,
dude, you understand this is like the
prevailing opinion, right? This is like
the prevailing opinion amongst all of
these people. Do you not understand that
going after this guy is really stupid
for you? I have no sympathy for Han
either, but Destiny should be in jail as
well alongside Han. Dude, LIKE WHY ARE
YOU APPEALING to these people? Why are
you like leaning into this? It doesn't
make any sense. All of these people know
these are the Aspen Gold fans. They see
no difference between Hassan and
Destiny. They think they're basically
the same.
I'm telling you, they think they're
basically the same. I don't know why.
Why would you lean into this? It's so
stupid. There is another point here.
Real quick, real quick. Real quick.
>> Is that a little play on words I see
there? Because a little guy by the name
of Destiny, and I do mean little, a
little guy by the name of Destiny. Also,
>> excited about this.
>> How tall is he?
>> Every single person.
>> Actually, has the son ever called me
short before?
>> Oh, whoops. I'm sure he has. I'm
>> I don't know if he had I feel like every
person every man on the internet that
has called me short has been my height
or shorter in real life.
>> That's I feel like that has happened
with almost every single person. So he
actually Kyle is shorter than Chris.
>> This ninja's short. This ninja real
short. This ninja tiny,
isn't he? In their marriage photos.
>> Well, I tower over you. But
>> good one.
>> He's wrong on Kyle's height. Kyle is
taller than him.
>> How tall am I? 5'8.
Five. Eight.
>> Hold on. Let's check. Kyle Kolinsky.
Height.
Six.
>> Oh, no. Shot.
>> Eight.
>> No. Five. Eight. Five.
Is she like 5'10 or something? Is she
super Wait, is Destiny Is Destiny
shorter than Crystal Ball? Destiny
thinks the height difference between
these two people is 2 in. By the way,
Destiny looks at this and he goes,
"Yeah, it's about 2 in." Yeah, it's
about two inches right there for ultra
tall. Him near Joe Rogan. How tall is
Joe Rogan?
>> It looks so insecure to cope about this.
It's It's so insecure to cope about
this, bro.
>> Joe Rogan
like 56, right?
>> Guy by the name of Destiny, and I do
mean little. A little guy by the name of
Destiny also is excited about this and
thinks it's awesome. This is putrid,
wretched, repulsive, disgusting.
None of these people believe in
anything. Shut the up, you loser. You
know what? I take that back. If Kyle
Kolinsky has a video of him calling out
Hassan for cheering on Adam Schiff or
any of the other people who have been
threatened by this administration on the
left, then you know what? He probably
thinks it's a joke. And Kyle has a leg
to stand on. Oh,
>> you you can't say it's a joke. Just like
whenever you do something wrong, Destiny
can never go, "Oh, I was just kidding."
Because if he tries to go, "Oh, I'm just
kidding." Unfortunately, there's a
record of him doubling, tripling,
quadrupling down. Right? Like in this
moment where he is doubling down,
tripling down. No Hassan should be
arrested. No Cassan. In this moment,
he's doubling, tripling, quadrupling
down. And we can all see how fake he is,
how he doesn't hold any any kind of
principle at all. Even though some of
these people when Destiny got targeted
or even was perceived to be targeted,
they stood up for him because they
understand there's no difference to the
Manga regime between Destiny and
Kolinsky. There's no difference to those
guys.
Sit down and shut the up you virtue
signaling little [__] Get the out of
>> He's He's calling people little now.
It's so dude so insecure. When you take
someone else's insult, it means it
landed. You you take he gets called
short by Kyle Kolinsky and immediately
he tries to throw that back at Kyle
Kolinsky. That means the insult landed
for you, right? You think that's a good
insult. So you throw that insult back.
When I call Destiny little, by the way,
I don't mean in stature, although that
is obvious. I always mean like in terms
of his ego, in terms of his like
self-confidence. He is a little person.
He is a tiny little man, right? I don't
mean literally, although that would also
be true. I mean, in terms of like,
oh, his self-confidence,
in terms of I don't know, his
grandiosity as a person. There's just
nothing there. He's insubstantial. He's
very small. That was it for that. We We
have to keep on with Kyle video. We're
going to keep going with Kyle video.
Hassan voted for Kla. You break out your
PMP pom strongly enough and cheer for
her. Therefore, you deserve this. Are
you kidding me? Are you kidding me? The
pettiness, the vindictiveness, the how
embarrassing. And you you people want to
lead a movement. That's what you want to
do. You want to lead a movement. You
want to bring us out of this fascist
hellscape that we're in are like the
opposite of leaders. These people are
deeply deeply unserious. Again, the fact
of the matter is he's being targeted for
being a decent person. He's being
targeted for being a left-winger. This
is somebody said this is quite literally
the poem of like first they came for the
communists, right? Like this that's
that's what this is. First they came for
the socialists. That's what this is. and
you're going to sit there and cheer it
on. Well, guess what? You're on that
list. They make no distinction between
you and him. Do you not understand that?
Destiny, too raw, too real. Any And by
the way, let me be clear. There's no
like no Democratic voters are cheering
this on. It's only like
>> Exactly. Exactly. There's no distinction
for these people. Why the are you
cheering cuz somebody just like That's
the whole man.
>> That's the whole point of having a
principal, dog. That's the whole point
is that even if you hate somebody, you
should stand on your principles or else
they will wither away and rot.
Obviously, man, weird media pundit
freaks who are way too online. They make
no distinction. You and Hassan are
exactly the same to them. They view, oh,
there's no difference between you guys.
You're all left of center. Like, that's
all they need to know. They'd throw us
all in camps if they could. THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING THAT WITH ICE. God forbid
you're you're an immigrant. God forbid
you make a joke about Charlie Kirk. God
forbid you're pro Palestine, they will
lock you up or kick you out of the
country. People have been tortured and
in SECOT. They're building concentration
camps all across this country for the
ICE Castapo thugs for Trump's
paramilitary. And you're going to sit
there and cheer on when a prominent
left-winger gets targeted for doing
humanitarianism. You're going to cheer
that on? You're going to support that?
No soul. No soul, no morality, no
ethics, no consistency. It is
embarrassing. It is pathetic. Put aside
your childish petty. Who gives a about
your childish petty internet beef? Are
you serious? This is the real I do think
like shockingly Hassan also put it to
the side for Destiny to like argue on
his behalf. Like actually for real,
which to me like I do think Destiny's
got Hassan about a thousand times more
than Hassan's got back at him. I was
shocked that Hassan was willing to put
it to the side to support Destiny when
he felt like Destiny might be targeted,
right?
real world that we're talking about
here. What a sick joke. Never in a
million years will you ever see me cheer
on. If the Trump regime goes after uh
you know a neoliberal uh online creator,
never in a million years would I sit
there and cheer that on because I know
that they make no distinction between me
and that person. None whatsoever. I know
that it's an injustice that it's
violating their rights. What a sick
joke, man. What a sick joke. So, you
know some demonic is happening when Nick
Fuentes and Laura Loomer both agree. The
one who allegedly sucked Trump off and
the one who wants to suck Trump off when
the closet case uh manlit not Nick
Nick's likes Nick loves slighter builds.
Nick would never get involved with Trump
in that way. Okay. Nick would never get
involved with Trump in that way. He
likes He likes dudes that are slight to
build. Okay. Come on. Come on. Kyle,
don't do misinrespat
Kyle. That is slander. That is the
height of slander, sir. You know
something's up. You know, you know, some
horrible is about to go down. So, uh,
you know, as as his son always says,
judge him by his enemies. And I think uh
everybody with a functioning brain can
do that in this scenario and realize um
they hate him. They're scared of him. He
represents every single thing that
they're not. Uh and they want to make
him pay for that. They want to make him
pay for that. They want to make him pay
for daring to support innocent people
who are being embargoed by us and
starved by us. That's a crime. But kids
on Epstein Island, not a crime. uh
committing countless countless instances
of fraud on Wall Street. Not a crime.
Trump pardons fraudsters on a daily
basis. Committing immense corruption on
a regular basis. You are such a gaycoded
straight dude sometimes. Also, you are
correct. Hey, I I understand people of
all walks of life. Okay. I'm cursed with
being the most empathetic you. No,
probably not. I'm cursed with
understanding Nick Fentes's gayness.
Okay. That's I'll say we'll keep it to
that. I I just understand how and why
he's gay. not a crime. Stop and think
about this. The same people who are
carpet bombing little girl schools in
Iran are saying Hassan is a criminal for
delivering the ramen noodles. I mean,
you can't you can't make this up. You
can't make this [__] up. We live in hell
and everybody needs to be crystal clear
on where they stand on this. And if
you're not, sorry, you're not one of the
good guys.
>> Now listen, now had a reaction to this
to the Kolinsky video.
>> I'm the one who wants to suck Trump off.
>> Yeah. Nick Fent and Laura Loomer agree.
So does Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold was like,
"Yeah, around and find out." Yeah.
Yeah. Lock him up again. Content creator
on this goddamn platform. Literally
supposed to be
somewhat of a colleague here. Dude, I
love that Hassan Listen, I I listen, I
love Hassan, but I know for a fact that
if I had to like stand
shoulder-to-shoulder, if Hassan was in
this drama and he's like the same size
creator as like me or Queen or or
Dickers or Aiden, I feel like Hassan
would be out the door. Okay, a little
bit. A little bit. I I love Hassan, but
he is like I can feel him wavering even
though he knows he's right. Like I can
feel that he is like he's a little
spooked. You know what I mean? Like, how
should I put it? Hassan has the right
positions. Hassan has the right morals,
but you could tell that if he was if he
was like a military general, he'd be
like kind of he'd have a little catch in
his voice. There's no iron in this guy.
You know what I mean? Which isn't the
worst thing in the world, but I I could
feel that he's like Asmin Gold isn't
even supporting me. We're like
colleagues. I have to be a little
respectable about colleagues. No, man.
No, you're you're the guy. That's why we
need to support him. Okay. We need to be
the iron in his in his spine for him.
All right.
>> It's elevating the prospect.
>> He stands tall. He can stand tall. I'm
just laughing that you could tell he's
like expecting his friends to help a
little bit and ask Cole's not your
friend anymore, man.
>> Salivating at the prospect of me uh
being arrested.
>> Dork. It's crazy.
>> He's like, "There's a very easy solution
for this. Bring in the National Guard,
round them all up, and put them IN
FORCED LABOR CAMP. GET the ones who are
violent and attack police done. You can
literally solve this problem overnight,
but we choose to allow these animals to
run wild. Elon Musk 100.
>> Do you idiots not understand what
anything like a society due process any
of that? I mean, it's crazy. Also, what
is that [__] Why do people listen to
that guy? He's disgusting. And then
Aspen Gold will be like, "Don't call me
a fascist. Somebody might kill me." He
argues for camps where they round people
up and basically the ones who are
violent. Round them all up. Put them in
forced labor camps. Anybody who fights
back them. And then it's like, "Dude,
you might be a fascist." He's like,
"Hey, hey, WHAT ARE YOU SAYING? SOMEBODY
SHOULD, BRO. YOU JUST SAID ROUND THEM UP
UP. ROUND THEM ALL UP AND SHOOT HIM.
What the are you talking about?" But if
you call this guy a fascist, apparently
that's too far. That's like a bridge too
far.
Don't call me a fascist. You want
somebody to show up and shoot me. What
the man? Like, I get how Asenold might
say, "But I'm just saying the violent
ones." If your goal is to round them up
and put them in labor camps, isn't that
the precise situation you should get
violent in? That's a tyrannical
government. Isn't that what the Second
Amendment is for? I think one more. I've
got an Asold clip. Oh, yes. This is the
Asold reaction today to Kyle Klinsk's
clip. The clip from Kyle Klinsky's video
on Hassan.
>> Get the out of here. So, I understand
something. Why would they target Hassan
[__] Because Hassan [__] is
everything they hate and everything they
can't control and everything they're
scared of. Hassan.
>> So what are you talking Okay,
>> per he's out there fighting for Medicare
for all. He's out there fighting for
free college. He's out there fighting
for living wage. He's out there fighting
against is
>> he's out there fighting for Hamas.
That's the problem. Nobody's against
Hassan fighting for Medicare for all.
Nobody's against Hassan fighting for,
you know, more livable wages. Nobody
>> does Hassan bring Hamas up when he goes
to do his dreams.
>> Who's ever against that?
>> Everybody said, you know what, we might
not agree with you, but that's not it.
Whenever you support literal terrorists,
then it's going to be different. I don't
know why these people try to
misunderstand
real. And and this is this is the
problem that a lot of these leftist
people have is that they are inside of
this cult of just constantly and
intentionally misunderstanding every
single criticism against them and then
attacking as if they're being attacked
for something that isn't even happening.
like they're they're they're like
addicted or sorry, you could say
addicted to, but like afraid of being
able to acknowledge any sort of
legitimate criticism.
>> Yeah. He's out there fighting against
the Epstein class who controls the Trump
regime.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And they can't have that. Especially
since now he's gaining national
prominence. Especially since now he's
endorsing Democratic candidates. And
when he does that, those Democratic
candidates are going up 10 points like
Abdul Elsed, right? So if anything, this
is going to backfire. This is going to
make Hassan a bigger figure. he becomes
more loved by democratic voting base cuz
>> I think that's not what's going to
happen. I think that that he has too
many positions that are just simply
unamerican fundamentally
>> like what and there are so many really
bad clips like you know for example
saying that it's like better that like
white women get because they're be it's
it's like it's like a harm. That's not
the clip. Dude, these people suck at
sarking so badly. This is what I'm
talking about. Like you have to be a
total drone to enjoy this. You have to
be a complete drulian to enjoy this.
LIKE LIKE YOU COULD START THAT CLIP.
THAT CLIP IS BAD. It it sounds bad. It
probably is bad, but that's not how you
set it up. Reduction or something like
that. Like if you play that clip, I'm
sorry, but like a lot of women are going
to say that's disgusting. Like you're
not going to have women that are going
to say, "Oh yeah, le let's go ahead and
have this guy speak for us." The 9/11
clip. Yeah. Well, at least the 9/11
clip, you could say that he Oh, he was
talking about Americans, you know, like
it was like a geopolitical thing, right?
He wasn't saying they deserved it
personally. The other ones are way
worse, but grabbing by the is okay.
Well, I think people criticized Trump
about that, too. They didn't like that.
I I don't think a lot of people like
that.
>> The Democratic voters already love
Hassan for what he stands for if they
know him, right? They know him as the
tax the rich guy. They know him as the
>> as the tax the rich guy. No, they don't.
They know him as the guy that shocked
his dog. That's why when you type in
Hassan, the first result is dog.
>> I mean, you could say that, but
he is objectively like doing great
political work right now. Unlucky.
>> That's what everybody knows him by is by
the dog thing.
>> Okay,
>> it's literally that simple. Like, I
mean, you can just look this up
immediately and you can just prove this.
>> Universal healthcare guy. They know him
as the anti-genocide guy. the anti-
genocide guy. Is that right?
>> Now he's also being persecuted by the
fat imperialist
con man president
>> war criminal like now all of them are
going to go oh well I'm definitely on
this guy's side again. Medadia Benjamin
same thing. We love media.
>> Not a single correction there. Not a
single correction. Yeah it all sounds
about right. Yeah it all sounds about
right actually. Yeah. Yeah
Benjamin. We love Coping. Exact same
thing. This just makes them more
prominent, more wellknown if you wanted
to find a way to get normie Democrats to
support him.
>> And I think that there is a risk for
this. And I think that what Kyle is
saying is partially accurate. I think
this is a great bit of evidence that you
need to completely crush these people.
Let's go. Aspoy pulling out full
fascism. Let's go. We just need a we
just need everybody. We should just say
civil war, civil war, civil war. Asmin
Gold, Tim Pulark, let's go. You never
take half measures. If they are breaking
the law or they're doing something
that's illegal, you have to completely
crucify them. You don't because it you
you can't let them be a martyr. You
can't take half measures and then
they're able to
Does he know what martyr means? Does he
know the definition of martyr?
Does he have any idea what that word
means? You you can't let them be a
martyr. So crush them mercilessly. It's
like wait, do you wait do you are you
sure you know what that word means? As
are you good? Are you good? Like look at
what happened for example with Trump,
right? They
wait. He did say crucify them. Oh no.
Can anybody name Off the top of my head
I can't possibly name a martyr who is
crucified. Wait guys, is there like a
famous martyr of some kind that has ever
been crucified? Has that crucify them so
that they don't turn into a martyr? This
guy's brain is man. This guy's brain is
broken,
dude. It hurt.